the second critical response occurs when
white plays d5 and here if you remember
my previous video I recommend that you
should play d6 and the most aggressive
reply here by a white is Bishop to b4
afterwards I recommend that black should
capture this phone and after Knight
cross ePHI black should play Queen to D
file now in that video I have covered
most of the usual response except two
moves which is Queen to e2 and Queen to
h5 checks and this both are very
critical move so let's deal each by tone
first of all let's consider a queen to
e2 so idea fight is very simple not only
why it is protecting both the piece but
why don't Stu play Knight to c3 gaining
more time on the Queen well if this kind
of ideas are successful against the
Colorado gambit then nobody would like
to play Colorado gambit but fortunately
for us Black has a very strong move at
this position and that is Queen cross
beat and after rook to F in because the
Queen to h5 check is looming Black has
to play Knight to f6 now here I have
crew games for you in one of my game my
opponent decided to capture this node so
Knight cross night and after B cross C
six White has managed to give black a
double pole and stopping black to castle
on the Queen side well that's the
downside the plus side is now the
planning of the campaign from the black
perspective is very easy so after Bishop
to a4 I switch my plan and I now decided
to go on the King side so I played a six
and hear my opponent responded with the
move D for free of his other Bishop and
I can play Bishop to d6 at this point
but I decided to first grab a semi-open
file with my rope so I played rook to b8
and now my opponent responded with
Bishop to b3 its idea is to attack the
loose c6 phone which is weaker right now
after a long thinking I come out with a
very cunning move which is Knight to d5
and at first sight it looks like a
mistake because can't white get this
night with the move c4 but believe it or
not this is what exactly black was
hoping for after c4 I played a very
strong move which is Bishop to b4 check
and the first melt is white cannot play
Knight to c3 in the game my opponent
responded with Bishop to d2 but now
comes the whole point of Knight to d5
because now I can play Knight to f4 and
because this bishop is pinned right now
this Knight is attacking the Queen so in
the game I upon responded with Queen to
e3 but afterwards I played another
strong move which is Queen to g4 so now
the idea is very simple I want to play
Knight to G to check and foking king and
a queen
unfortunately for white white cannot
move the Queen because if the Queen
moves to anywhere then Queen - II - we
leads to checkmate so again here after a
long thinking my opponent come out with
the only strong move which is f3 but
afterwards black has a winning position
so I simply played Knight - G - check
and after King - e - I just capture the
Queen and after why to recapture the
Queen I just capture the rook and after
Bishop takes Bishop and rook takes
Bishop if you look at this position
clear exchange up so that is one game
which highlight how you can play against
Knight cross c6 variation in another
game my opponent come out with this move
which is the move d4 which is a more
stable move but against this black
planning of campaign will be remain same
so black wants to quickly develop the
Queen side and go through the queenside
castling so I played Bishop to d7 which
has a cunning idea of capturing the
night so my opponent responded with
Knight cross d7 and here I played a
strong move which is night cross b7
right now indeed black is threatening to
capture the D pawn
and in one of my game my opponent played
the very passive licking move c3
afterwards I simply castle on the cream
side and on the very next move I played
ePHI and because white king is stuck in
the center white is having a very hard
time so that is the idea if you open who
plays as passive moves such as c3 in
another game where my opponent was a
higher attained so he decided to go
through the attack so he played Bishop
to f4 attacking the c7 and probably he
thought that I cannot capture the d4
pawn but to his horror I indeed capture
this one at first sight it looks very
very dangerous because white goes for
this line so he captured my knight which
allows my King come into the center so
King cross d7 and afterwards he played
Queen to b3 pinning the night and
probably he didn't think beyond on this
but here comes the whole thing because I
had know that he's going for this and I
have something surprise for him so I
played Queen to e4 chat and please
if the King moves then I will capture
the White Queen that way white pawn will
be all over the place
so my opponent has to capture this way
and after I recaptured all right now
black is threatening to capture on c2 so
my opponent has to play move such as
Knight 23 which is not at all a bad mood
because it looks passive at first sight
but idea of white is very simple white
wants to castle on the Queen side and
then this night will be pin so that's
why I have to play very very accurate
moves over here here I play a strong
move which is Knight to f3 check so
stopping any queenside castling and my
opponent responded with King to e2
afterwards I simply play e5 and after
rook check which looks very national but
it's not a good move because I played
King to c6 and King to c6 probably the
strongest move of the game because it's
stopping Knight coming to the b4 and
also stopping group coming to the d4 nor
ever why has to move this Bishop right
now so in the game my opponent plays
Bishop to e3 afterwards I simply snap up
the 9th and after white recapture I
played rook to d8 and be devoted to go
further from here look at the white
pawns they are all over the place black
has a compact bone structure and black
is also a to pawn ahead
those are the two games which give you
the insight what you should do when you
open place Queen to it to the second
critical line occurs when white give
this check with Queen to h5
and here black has to respond with the
g6 and after night cross g6 then most
nature looking move Knight to f6 leads
to disaster so please remember this idea
never play Knight to f6 in this
variation I will show you what happens
when you play Knight to f6
because after Knight to f6 why it has a
very very strong move which is Knight to
f5
so not only giving a check to the black
king but also attacking the black queen
so black response is pretty much force
black has to capture the screen
afterwards white will recapture the
Queen and not only white is a clear pawn
up at this point but white has also idea
of capturing the c7 so probably black
has to move the King and if white wishes
white can also give black a double pawn
in those circumstances white will be the
one who is the boss of the game so
that's why I don't recommend Knight to
f6 at this point instead of this black
has a very strong move which is Queen to
e4 check this is a very crucial point
because white King can only go to the f1
because if the King goes to the d1 that
was a couple of times happen in one of
my games then the very simple will be
now you clay Knight to f6 and now Queen
has two places to go in either cases
white will lose the game so let's see
each by ton so if the Queen goes to the
h3 then the very simple will be fo
if the Queen goes to the h4 then the
very simple will be queen cross g2 which
has a matter of attacking the both the
piece and if the knight captures rook
Queen captures rook comes with a check
and after King to e2 black can simply
snap up the bishop so that is one game
which highlight what you should do when
your opponent plays King to d1 so most
critical response over here will be King
to have fun afterwards black has to play
Knight to f6 and here white has the only
strong move which is Queen to h4 and
here comes the big surprise to your
opponent because we are going to do the
exchange sacrifice with H cross g6 at
first sight it doesn't look like it has
enough compensation but the whole idea
is black will do a rapid fast develop
lane where white all pcs are slipping so
let's see some of my games from here
onwards I have two games here for you in
both the games my opponent capture the
rook and afterwards I just goes for this
forcing sequence so I played Queen cross
c2 and after very natural light to c3 I
played Bishop to d7 9s very simple I
want to castle on the Queen side and
quickly go for the attack in one of my
game
my opponent plays the move g3 afterwards
I simply play a6 attacking the bishop so
Bishop drop backs to the a4 I give the
white this check so Queen to d3 check
and after very nature looking King to g2
which free of that rope I just castle on
the Queen side and in the game my
opponent decided to activate his rook as
quickly as possible
so he played a group - even but this is
a one kind of disaster happens when you
play passive and here I played the
exceptionally strong move which is night
2
nine to be four has a clear idea to put
night on c2 so in the game my opponent
decided to defend the threat with Bishop
to b3 but afterwards I simply play
Bishop to c6 check and after King to g1
I simply play Queen to f3 and white is
hard-pressed to stop the meet
now in the second game instead of g3 at
this point my opponent has analyzed this
line with the help of engine and he come
out with this to exceptionally strong
move Queen moves which is first of all
Queen to h4 and after I castle on the
Queen side
he played Queen to a4 so I think this is
probably the strongest line in this ePHI
variation and you have to know what to
do against this in case you up and study
this line with engine here black this
pulse is pretty much first black has to
capture this Queen and after why to
recapture black has to play this space
gaining move which is e for so right now
if you look at the position black is a
clear Eckstein down but black has a
center and black PCs are more active
than the white pieces nor ever why it
has a loose pawn on d2 so let's see how
the game progress so here my opponent
plays the move d3 which has a light of
free of that Bishop I continue with the
knight to be four so attacking the
bishop and also attacking the d3 first
of all my opponent free of his Bishop
with Bishop to g5 attacking my nine and
I simply define it with Bishop to g7 and
now he play rook to d1 but after very
simple Bishop captures and Knight
captures I just snap up that phone and
after King to e2
I simply played efore so now it's a
matter of whose position is better why
it has exchange but black has a one pawn
plus a centralized knight in the game my
opponent decided to play route to d2
afterwards I played rook to e8 which has
an idea of first of all free of this
night which was pin and the second idea
is after black plays the move B file and
the knight moves there are some tactics
looming based on this B 2 square seeing
all this my opponent plays the move b3
but my opponent's last move b3 it's a
big big tactical blunder because I
simply play the move B Phi attacking the
knight and after Knight drawbacks to the
v2 I simply played Knight 2 X 7 and you
can see right now 2 pcs are hanging and
white cannot defend both the PCs so in
the game my opponent decided to capture
my knife but after very simple pawn
captures comes with a check my opponent
has to grab the pole and that allows me
to capture another piece so I played
Knight cross Bishop and now you can see
Black has two pieces against the rook
and still you think black is not that
much fun but this position is more
dangerous than it looks in the game my
opponent decided to play h4 attacking my
night so I played my night the e4
attacking his rope and the route goes to
the e2 so pinning my 9 but I can easily
unpin this so I give this check so Rupe
to da check and after King to c2 I play
this wonderful move which is rook to d6
here probably my opponent was in time
trouble so he played the move f3 which
allow me to finish the game very very
quickly so I played rook to c6 attacking
the King and please note if the King
goes to the d3 then the route to c3 will
be a checkmate so in the game my
opponent decided to play king to be one
but after very simple Knight to c3 check
and king to see - my opponent doesn't
have anything only to resign the K so
that is one game which gives you a very
good idea how to handle Queen to h4
check